quand vous avez des leaders en europe de
l'est qui disent nous nous avons choisi
des valeurs et elles sont sans doute
réactionnaire à vos yeux et c'est le
christianisme et c'est une certaine
vision de l'homogénéité européenne là
ils sont pointés du doigt comme étant le
camp du mal comme étant aux ordres des
valeurs européennes la pologne
typiquement d'ailleurs à ce sujet de la
marine le pen était gris de ce sujet là
j'aimerais bien qu'on écoute de seconde
les ménages de sanctions et a fortiori
d'exclusion qui sont d'une rare violence
à l'égard de la hongrie ou de la pologne
témoigne de l'enjeu du débat qui s'ouvre
j'aime venir union européenne c'est bien
qu'elle joue là son bateau les nations
savent que dans ce débat juridique elles
jouent leur existence
consciente de cet important je me suis
engagé dès mon élection à réformer la
constitution française par référendum
pour acter le principe de sa supériorité
parce que quel que soit votre rapport
avec marine le pen vous êtes d'accord
sur cette source qu'elle dit l'un sur le
fait que mais cette violence de l'union
européenne qui se manifeste en plus par
des parts des voix économique c'est à
dire si vous n'acceptez pas oui c'est un
amiral et les valeurs qu'on veut vous
imposer pas d'argent c'est comme ça que
ça se joue et c'est ça qui est
scandaleux c'est à la fois l'union
européenne a été là pour aider ces pays
à construire un état fort pour lutter
contre la corruption aussi dans certains
états de la nouvelle accession mais
aujourd'hui on voit bien que c'est
devenu une un ordre moral et c'est ça
qui est inacceptable l'europe ne peut
pas détenir la morale et politique et
philosophique chaque pays peut
s'organiser de la façon dont il entend
le problème de l'allocution de marine le
pen c'est de faire croire que parce que
on changerait quelques lignes de la
constitution on résoudrait le problème
les traités nous lie toujours donc il va
falloir revenir sur les traités or
comment on fait il faut être plusieurs